I design theater shoes and my interests
in the last few years have been looking
at more tactile technology especially
for very young children my particular
area is is to look at the way children
interacts with objects and whether we
can add some digital technologies to
those objects when you say interactive
so we're not talking about just clapping
and booing and hissing when the
pantomime
daddy comes on right no because you're
looking at very very young children and
they like to touch everything
so you're making things within the the
world of of off theater where you might
interact with something like a true your
voice so you might shout or talk or or
clap or again like in pantomime but this
way not only the actors are interacting
with you but the objects are interacting
with you so for example in the show I
recently did the run away here we had a
tree and in the interaction of the tree
you talked Sherrill funnels and the tree
will begin to light up now that that
tree lights up according to your voice
if you whisper you get low interaction
if you speak louder you get the lights
moving much faster the microphones are
they're attached to a microcontroller
which is a small floor made by Adafruit
and we program it using Arduino
programming 50 strip of LED lights are
then attached at microcontroller this is
then enclosed in a tree which we made
with cellotape so we are interested in
both the aesthetics and the use of
technology so we do not want to
compromise the aesthetics within theater
but also include some level of
interaction do you think that we need to
sort of tech for children well we find
that more and more children at this age
group are using apps so therefore
they're growing up with this sort of
level of interaction on on the screen
some parents are worried about these
others and and so you find that that
they're already touching toys and
playing toys I'm looking for that sort
of interaction
having that in theater I think it's a
natural for me it's that sort of natural
progression to making that interactive
it allows like I find it allows the
parent and the child to may be interact
and play but it adds an additional layer
we took them along a pathway to a meadow
now the idea of this entire show was
that they were looking for here so each
item in some way they were going to
interact and maybe give them clues of
where this here might be this is like
the rabbit style hair right so he's
hidden somewhere in the piece and so
they're after looking for him and so
they enter onto this meadow which is
been recreated with pressure sensors at
the bottom of them the pressure sensors
react to very very light touch so a tree
rules with a team on tall width will
allow a pressure sensor to trigger sound
so we the rabbit was hidden in this
giant flower on the bottom of the flower
we had stroke sensors now stroke sensors
are made with the kind of conductive
shred mixed with any other tread but
here we use the kind of furry fabric and
we mixed in the conductive thread with
the furry fabric at the back of the
fabric you need to have two strips of
conductive material and then you stitch
in the conductive treads in it that then
again is attached true either conductive
treads or wires to aboard another
microprocessor board because what
happened is that the children tickled
the flower and the flower laughed and
this is where they discovered the hair
so it was the hair was doing a sort of
comical laugh at the bottom so we had
five of those and there were five
children and so they can all sort of
tickle the senses we were interested in
kind of soft sensors and this the soft
sensors you kind of handmade to give
that tactile interaction so part of this
is that children at that age love
tactile interaction and so we were
really interested in in how we can use
different ways on different sensors for
that sort of interaction so these stroke
sensors is there something we've kind of
come up with this is custom
if you go onto the onto the web you will
you will find different types of stroke
senses a small stroke senses here I've
integrated it with a normal fabric that
already has full on to it so it's
something I've adapted from stroke
senses that are much smaller so we were
looking at increasing the size of things
for theater technically we were looking
at Bluetooth devices that we can look at
in terms of if you had a lot of audience
that were running around in a space and
you wanted to then identify that
particular audience we wanted them to
come together as a group you might then
use sort of Bluetooth wearables and so
on they're not as all cost-effective and
having about five or ten Bluetooth
devices in one place it's rather
difficult so part of the research was
looking at a wider area I suppose with
more Android experiments
we'd be able to develop better and
better interaction there's a lot more
tater theaters that are looking at
emissivity it's been going it's been
around since the 70s but it's been
growing recently lots of people want to
do more and a lot of theater companies
find that a lot more people find it's
more interesting to come to a theater
where they can move around the space
rather than just sit up on a seat and so
I think more and more theaters do to
that if people are interacting with
different things maybe that mono theater
companies would be interested in in this
technology as it allows it allows almost
the technology to become like the actor
in some way the technology is acting at
that point because it's triggering in
the sound or triggering the light or
triggering vibrations
I'm gonna have to ask the question
because computer file viewers would be
wondering about your accent
please tell us where's your thing it's a
Trinidadian accent I was born in the UK
but grew up in Trinidad been here for a
while